the internet and technology created an
idea of infinity and the reason why life
is beautiful is because it is
fundamentally limited this may be like
the last interaction we have and there's
something beautiful in that whereas if
you can play The Legend of zeld and just
hit restart it doesn't have that feeling
I think things that are limited in
nature are more valuable than things
that are unlimited scarce resources are
is the most valuable and so if time is a
scarce resource or life is a scarce
resource it would be inherently more
valuable we've seen all the vampire
movies how they Envy the ephemerality of
life for humans same thing with the
Greek gods used to say they envied
humans because things were more
beautiful because they were temporary I
think there's some truth to that if
they're just talking about life in
general